المنطقه كما تشاهدين منطقه نائيه لا توجد
فيها الا هذه الخيم البدائيه وبعض الخيم
التي قدمها الهلال الاحمر التركي وهيئه
افاد اليوم اردت العوده الى هذه المنطقه
كنت متفائل حقيقه بان اجد ان الوضع قد
تغير لكن مع الاسف خيم قليله فقط اتت الى
هنا ولم يتم استقدام خيم تكفي لجميع
العائلات الموجوده هنا حتى انني قبل ايام
التقيت بحسن وهو احد الناجين بقي تحت
الانقاض لمده اربع ثلاث ساعات تقريبا
اجرينا معه مقابل لقناه العربيه وكان
يعاني ايضا في تلك الاثناء من عدم وجود
خيمه واليوم ايضا فوجئت بانه حتى الان لم
يجد خيمه ساحاول ان اسال السيد حسن حتى
الان ليش ما قدرتوا تاخذوا خيمه والله
حاولنا يعني مره وتنتين وثلاثه واربعه
وحتى المختار الحاره انا حكيت معه بالذات
قال لي روح خذ خيمي اذا بتلاقي خيمه فاضيه
خذها وضل ماشي نحن مستعدين نسمع كلمه او
نسمع بهذه لان عمري بحدوده 60 سنه اذا بدي
شيل الخيمه بالشارع واسمع كلمه اذا ما
اعطونا اياها هني انا سبق وعملت معي
مقابله من ثلاث اربع ايام ثلاث ايام انت
طلع شو بتشوف الخيمه اللي بارك فيها البرد
الشيء ما بينوصف نحن كل شيء طالبين وخيمه
والتدفئه فقط لا غير البرد كتير حقيقه
صبرا يعني برد اكثر ما تصور خاصه بالليل
يعني بالنار هلا يعني برد شوي مقبول بس
بالليل بالليل صبرا يعني بشيء ما بنوصف طب
ما حدا وعدكم بموعد قريب انه ممكن تستلموا
خيمه او في موعد معين يعني انا عم شوف مو
بس حضرتك في كتير عائلات موجوده هون كمان
مع انه قيم في كثير عائلات في كثير عائلات
ما عندها هلق لحد تاريخ الساعه في خيام في
عائلتين وثلاثه حتى المطر ما بتوقي مطر لا
برد ولا مطر ولا شيء خالص تنزيل مطر البشر
كلها بتتبهدل انا حاولت اخذت خيمه بدي
اعطوني خيمه بالكراجات في ضمن الكراجات
يعني ساعتين انا وزوجتي اجمدنا بالخليط
مستحيل حدا يحسن يقعد خيمه يعني هون
بهالمنطقه راح بشغل نار بيتدفى له شويه
نار بيجيب صوبه اعطوك اياها ما فيها شيء
اللي خلقه والله سلموني السحاب فقط لا غير
على البلاط على الارض في ارض الاوتوجار في
ارض في ارض الكراج ونحن انا عندي زوجتي
سبق وحكيت مع مريضه بالقلب اني معصب ماميه
بالقلب الدفا البرد الا قاتل يعني
فنحن نتمنى خيمه مع التدفئه فقط لا غير
نحن وهالعوائلنا فقط لا غير اكل الحمد لله
موجود لباس موجود كل شي موجود ما عدا
التدفئه والخيمه يعني كل المساعدات موجوده
ما عدا وطبعا الخيمه هي الاهم بهذا الاهم
بالخيمه والتدفئه هي الاهم هي الخيمه اللي
بتستر وبتضب يعني فيها شويه دفا هي
الصعوبه فقط لا غير يعني اهم شيء من
ضروريات الحياه الخيمه والصوبه
شكرا السيد حسن